were it not for the war in ukraine the
starting point of this speech to tory
conference could have been so very
different
as we meet today a tragedy
continues to unfold in our european
continent boris johnson projecting
gravity promising security protecting
against risk if putin succeeds in
crushing ukraine it will be the green
light for autocrats everywhere in the
middle east in the far east
this
is a turning point
for the world and it's a moment of
choice it's a choice
between freedom
and oppression
seeking sometimes crudely to join the
dots between the fight against
depression and ukraine and the freedoms
he seeks for britain too
it's the instinct of the people
of this country
like the people of ukraine to choose
freedom every time
when the british people voted for brexit
in such large numbers i don't believe it
was because they were remotely hostile
to to foreigners
it's because they wanted to be free
then this an incendiary charge that a
furious labour party rejects entirely
that his opponents would not stand up to
putin
do we want them in charge my friends at
this moment do we want them running up
the white flag
do you see them standing up to putin's
blackmail
it's not normal to have a tory
conference like this one with the prime
minister delivering a foreign policy
heavy speech but the political message
isn't that subtle boris johnson was
telling his activists a story about a
government with purpose that's
delivering with morality at its core
very different from the kind of
headlines these activists were reading
about earlier in the year
six weeks ago plenty of tories were
talking about ousting boris johnson from
number 10.
they won't be doing that now i think
everybody's behind him he's actually got
all the cabinet and all the
conservatives behind him now does
anybody think it matters if the police
decide to issue him with a fine for
breaking rules during partygate no he's
an excellent leader which will lead the
country
i say partygate you say
boris johnson's oldest friend in cabinet
accepts his fortunes have changed since
the war in ukraine i don't think there
is any conspiracy sam i think if the
let's just see when this report arrives
but at the same time i think we are all
reminded that in many parts of the world
what is on their mind is their security
their economy recovery post covered
but tory mp's not quite ready to face
the electorate yet ready for an action
next year
i hope not i've got lots to do in
stockholm trent central
deconstructing this conference it
appears the party has given boris
johnson another chance but will the
voters walk away sam coats sky news
blackpool